[Music]
times change
you do what you gotta do some kids most
employers don't want mothers it's a
competitive market you don't know me for
money you survive
now might be the time so what feel my
husband's have 24 months left on her
senses sorry baby this is divers mother
organized crime we're gonna take care of
you you're gonna be just fully we got no
money can't even make the rent with what
they gave me last night
they didn't want me in the family in the
first place
40 years they pay protects you don't we
don't get nothing for it
HIPAA Thomas for effort that we are
never gonna do anything but have babies
bunch of men that have forgotten what
family means so we remind them no pretty
mama pretty doesn't matter it's just a
tool women use what anything we want
what do you want you're gonna have crews
everywhere can see you got brains and I
know you got money but we got one thing
that you don't
criminals so you can't go around water
for a bunch of women who are not smarter
than me I was like you off the face of
the earth I don't want you to die I'm
gonna teach me how to it
just to be clear now we run this
neighborhood
[Music]
step off my business baby it's my
business left they're gonna swallow this
entire city
you go to war there's no coming back
also Caretti wants to talk if we go to
Brooklyn we're dead
what are you wear to something like that
get dressed up kitty
[Music]
my god I lost count again
[Music]
[Music]
you